on jun 15 2012 film courage attended a
press conference for the new Woody Allen
film to Rome with love this audio is the
entire 15 minute Los Angeles press
conference featuring commentary from a
writer director woody allen actors
Penelope Cruz Ellen Page Greta Gerwig
Alison Pill and alessandra Mastronardy
for more information on to Rome with
love please visit sony classics calm /to
wrong with love how compatible our date
with your side oh they don't have to
test them because they're perfect for a
trip in any way compatible I didn't
think Roberto Benigni would be I thought
that you would be that have a difficult
time with him that he would be a
repressible and I never be able to get
his attention and running around not
crazy and I have to but in the end it
turned out that he was blinded election
but boys and quiet and
pleasure to work with them we had
nothing to do some kind of comedy just
dishes roll twenties yet and everybody
well I directed it yet that's next
summer hi it is a part to meet them I
play it this is no fun as I got older
the parts have diminished you are I like
agenda I'd always play the lead in the
movie and I can do all the romantic
scenes with women and it was fun and I
like to play that now I'm older and I'm
reduced to playing stage doorman
something and I really love that so
patient we were taught himself but first
of all great Johnny fantastic
performances this question goes I'm
Alison pelvic movie teeming with leigh
allyn and what is the value I will it's
a joy and a privilege and an statistical
axis bill making Americans and I also
appreciate the idea that pills can be
just make them even if a job that's why
feels actor it's just I just like doing
Oh apt for anybody I'm very lucky that
it about me to do I feel it should be
that the final piece
I was very happy first of all too easy
to be able to spend time with him he
makes me laugh all day long so I feel
like that gives guarantee like thats
that time with him and also it to be
corrected by him and he caused me enough
to between these characters the only
thing is that is always too short
because both times i work with three
weeks trial was i was wondering one
thing I'm everyone's told me that you
just had to draw it and you pulled off
the draw me the troll different ideas at
your hand I think this is it or is this
some one of the ideas that you have your
drawer know that I you know ideas happen
in a drawer my house and then I go look
at that many of them seem very unfunny
and foolishly I can't imagine what I was
thinking when I originally did it but
sometimes I'll pull out an idea like
that we note written on a match for
another piece of regulations for example
a man who can only sing in the shower
and and it will occur to me that I'm
this could be a funny story and that's
what happened with is the work some
ideas in this movie that
notice it myself busy Fabio tube
signatory to do this when I below who
played the part of the singer in the
shower hard time convincing it or did he
yeah yeah we researched for a long time
to find somebody who actually sing opera
Adam to sweep the little English and
could have a little bit and there was
something that discovery was great he
had all the road and lived in the door
in here his wife you spoke English
pretty well it was pretty good actor and
had a lovely singing voice ask you about
you made some beautiful films up both
here and
in Europe and I just wondering what was
kind of the inspiration for realm was
edited what did you decide that you were
the study was going to be there and what
is about Rome that kind of appeal to you
for the setting for this film well two
things one is I talking about four years
with the people who distribute my films
i always said content and and finally
they said look come and do nothing about
it for a long time we'll put up all the
money necessary to make the film and
jumped at the chance I want it was an
opportunity to get the money quickly
from single source title versus the
helderberg mr. Allen is it inevitability
that it's a shoot in Rome they're going
to eventually shoot in a location from
an eight and a half or Fellini movie or
did you deliberately choose locations
that sort of record or similar probably
inevitable because we know but I didn't
know very well and the art director went
around finding pretty locations and
interesting location
said you know I had no idea if any of
them had appeared in other movies I mean
I was sure obviously I was shooting the
Coliseum or something like that probably
50 movie descent and that would be true
of number of the locations but I really
know where in shooting in many places I
seen for the first time many streets and
that's really the osterizer found all
beautiful location
for mr. Allen so much in the film is a
meditation on Fame accomplishment and
what might have sparked the idea to
focus the movie around that assignment
maybe then open it up to everybody else
how do you feel about Fame in your own
models at this point the fact that that
some of the film deals with that thing
is post facto I didn't think about that
when we made the film I I thought jeez a
funny idea the guy suits in the shower
it's a funny idea that some guy wakes up
one day and suddenly he's famous and
doesn't really know why and two young
people come to Rome and they just
married they get involved in the
situation I never thought of any somatic
connection in any way and that's all
just an accident that Raven something
that was on my unconscious at the time
and it came out in some strange way I
myself feel about paying the way the
character where the chauffeur talks
about in the movie that you know life is
tough and it's tough with your famous or
you're not famous and in the end it's
probably of those two choices better too
because you know the perks our data you
know you you get better seats at the
basketball game
tables and reservation spices and a
doctor on Saturday there's a lot of
things that indulgences if you don't get
if you just give your non things now I'm
not saying it's fair it's kind of
disgusting but I can't say enjoy and
there are drawbacks of things to what
you can live with those they're not like
fur you know the paparazzi outside your
restaurant or your house and and actors
makes a big thing of it scurry into cars
and drinks in them you know you think
they're going to be crucified it's not a
big deal used to that it's not available
so the grandsons greatly outweighed by
the reservation will connect today mr.
Allen gratitude in addition to being
accomplished filmmaker you're also quite
an accomplished musician your own right
using always plays an important part of
your films serving does in this one
could you talk about the importance of
music and your duties in this discussion
well I'm a big believer in music and
movies it covers a multitude of sins now
great direct a really great director
Birdman did not believe she thought the
use of musical films was barbaric and
his word and he his stones are great
enough so that he doesn't need any
outside help i need help i'm known as
for the first movie I ever made in my
life take the money and ran there were
scenes in it that will just die when I
looked at them in the cutting morning
and the editor Ralph rosenblum said
pretty soon news and I was so
inexperienced I didn't I didn't say he
amuses with this record of and in
further record on and all of a sudden
when I was doing something and it was so
boring originally it came to like it did
just the theater music just made the
whole thing work and ever since I've
been a big believer in supporting the
action on film with the appropriate
music and it's got me out a lot of jams
over the years so musically is a very
big thing in forms that i use it under
shame degree and use all the classics
all the great composers of classical and
jazz
it's the most pleasurable talking me to
do you have a movie and you live in it's
ice cold with no music then you stop
dropping in a little George Gershwin or
Mozart you know something else and
things suddenly becomes lively and
magical hunters great field hi Carolyn
in the film Alec Baldwin's character
takes a trip down memory lane if you
could go back and tell me what would you
tell you to jump herself don't do that I
don't know I would like to connect time
to adjust for lunch I'd like to live
there are all those throwbacks as I
mentioned my other movie you don't get
cooler than this you don't get it you
don't get you know the things that you
used to have cell phones and television
things that are very convenient it takes
over for the ambulance to come but it
would be fun if you could every now and
then just meet a friend for lunch at
Maxine's in Paris and 1900 or go back
and I'm dating Stephanie just a couple
of out let's take a walk in the park and
then come right back
Alan Alan Silverman Hollywood bikes
radio and this is for all of the actors
and I'm applying money that you're not
an actor it's also been said about you
that about what happened that he will
tell you just do it your way do in your
own words it's not precious about every
word of the stretch being apenas passive
is great I'm wondering in your
perspective on that how freaking is that
well perhaps is particularly frightening
because he's saying do it your way
calculator well in my case is been
different I think because my eggs were
was new talent so you could say
everything you want say he put later the
subtitle so for us but but for me I was
I was glad because I'm really free to
acting I feel the character so i think i
would think for us I don't know I'm not
that kind of actress and I need to
restriction to an eye on set it on and
we're pretty glad to be free and other
way the subtitle so I don't know it was
absolutely care
I too like yeah just say something else
I don't really I don't really like doing
that I am it's a wonderful challenge and
a totally exciting and terrifying thing
to do but you know it's I am NOT gifted
wordsmith most of the time and so I do
remember times just you know saying stay
up at night going but it is it is it is
a joy as well he gives all this freedom
which is very at the same time feels
like a big responsibility to go do
tamanho in anything and especially when
were working on a different language
that came to you know I've grown up javi
mi he gave us in English and ask for us
translated however however we want to
the way I was our characteristic and we
were with you soon abhi agra with are
going to click on the translation of
what we were
r
yes
I spent most my bike investigating
characters in his movies I 11 was trying
to talk like them so my terror he is
confused so for me I just was excited it
was hard for me to change the words and
the eye because I love them so much but
also because I just seems idea of humans
and the pair of juicy
Renee improvise it always sounds better
the stuff I write in my bedroom because
I don't know what's going on alone
isolated New York and we get on the set
and it feels different to the actors at
me and when they improvise they may be
you know they made it sound a lot in
Barcelona how do I developing what
improvising whenever they felt like and
they're speaking Spanish I'm single word
of Spanish and to this day their scenes
in the picture but I have no idea what
they were saying but you could tell they
were correct by their body language
by the emotions are going through and I
mean I did a half ago you know just
remember you're super in a free session
starting with something oh ok well I
don't know actually I think that maybe
in each me we have kind of thing so yeah
yeah if you if you are famous a very
important person and you call it a
restaurant if you're 17 about that table
for you maybe they do it but just maybe
one teach one time you want to time so I
don't know we have a different
relationship with insane first worry I
don't not what you feel Sam
since I like treat them well working on
building maybe I'm very last factories
that were damaged I got to thinking
about fake I'm not I'm time to think
about it so Allison outside I mean I
just consider myself to be a working
actor I don't have I I have no idea what
people would I mean I'm not famous I
don't get stopped on the street I just
if you know I don't like strangers so I
wouldn't look forward to I just you know
I'm waiting for the day when somebody
sends me that's all I want for free
thank you free stuff I'm like I don't
know what would I want I want a pet cake
baby knows me I don't know that I'm
famous and I want to get this money the
only good fear thing that I've taken
allie is to to experience it in first
person to realize the originals we all
happiness that comes out of it because
you know that you were better you are
going to detail
there is really we don't feel happiness
I your life because of that and I really
believe that the advantages are very
unfair and disgusting but I also think
that sort and disadvantages are pretty
tough and difficult to hear me to the
point where sometimes I have question if
I wanna continue this job because of
that cuz I don't care that a picture of
me and when lady pictures of your tummy
or you know right about your family or
especially when it's about children that
I can't tolerate it and I'm depends on
the country where you live children are
more protected away in the States there
is no protection control
mayor of children so I'm person against
that you know them all the magazines
have these few pages in the virus is
dedicated to the children object and
it's not a handbag so I that is a really
I don't care it should be but that goes
into a different territory that is in
that shouldn't be allowed
so there's
thanks
I not famous own but i do like New York
I knew each other too I am headed in
your house this is the other side of it
I just loosing New York bridge it's like
a level of actor like a lot of cedar
actors in New York think they're not
fancy people who get their fidgety I go
there all the time I only our comedians
to do something you see be here just
like around you feel so proud that you
identity this allegiant artists and
their they're under the radar in a way
like like I don't seem like ballet
dancers like I saw you excited I think
that level of like artistic community
and recognizing each other is really
nice and but that has a different thing
hi there red sign indiscretions again
for all the ladies interested in since
the film really consistently just needs
to screen narratives in large measure
you'll work with one another your ideas
impressions your speculation about what
the film for all these speaking would be
about and then impressions now let's
assume you ballsy write this assuming
that you all again we're only a tribute
to discrete and I love somebody I
thought I mean I thought it would feel
like it is it's romantic it's funny it's
Luke mistakes and mishaps but it's full
of hard there's something about Rome it
feels like this movie it feels like a
big and like at the same time I love it
there
Ellen I had just read the
cast ourselves
same i sorry I the other
did you like that came out actually
twice now and I wrote it down make me
laugh so much thinking about the guy
that can be seen in the shower is one of
his best performances he make so much
he's faced with he's listening to him
singing I mean I saw for the first time
last night and it was I mean what would
what a joy you know it's so barely going
to the cinemas now and you walk out like
happier and lighter than you did when
you walked in and I had a sense I mean
they're all these brilliant kind of
humorous short stories all kind of
intertwined and they each are standalone
standalone short film so it's sort of
thing we're definitely couldn't matter
what everybody else is doing you just
sort of going they've got their stuff I
gotta focus on whatever the heck I'm
trying to do but to see it all come
together in this amazing format of not
knowing
Corner but after whether reverb
immediately jump out yeah you know it's
just an exciting wonderful film to
washing they couldn't be more happy
grateful honor to you know be in it also
well last night was my third time so I
always enjoyed innovate meant I retire I
Sarah listen to me I discover something
much more beautiful and funny and that's
so amazing and what I knew her just like
absinthe and when I went on sat at
school and I was with Crusades Camille
was amazing in st. my Hollywood who was
a movie so every day was a living
experience because I didn't know
anything about that I really enjoyed it
moving even because to all my big dreams
are together the island and Rome that's
my two big train and in a ton of
language do because I was so curious
because I never see a movie with
everything language in China which
together and that's great something is
telling language making is the most
languages work not irrelevant you know
spanish french now
so any time it was want to do the last
one so it's a great thing for us so
amazing a magic Penelope was wondering
when playing these sort of quirky and
provocative characters do kind of need a
back story line for them and what was
the coolest part about this character
than the Wardrobe I was looking around
its own body sensation we didn't talk
about any particular it was just their
debates and maybe sign on Ely that saved
in everything she everything she thinks
comes out her but she does have a filter
and I love that because she should be
opposite proper I am I want to be like
that and I am much more in much more
about hopeful quick so I don't think
characters that are so so free you want
say whatever
we will include so much search / sticky
humor an absurdist kind of sight gags
and things like that and in that regard
it feels like it throw back to some of
your earliest films and I'm wondering
what inspired you to sort of return to
that approach the comedy of this plan
your career those stories that make up
room with a terrible title original
title was bop decameron and nobody knew
something i changed it Nero fiddles and
and half the countries in the world said
well we know where that means we don't
have expression is a member of movies so
find that settled on a generic title
everybody we get it and the stories in
this picture I just require that we're
telling those stories a certain amount
of that broader slapstick human not much
of it was written out of it is required
that it just and you can tell me story
I'm going you know you just can't tell
the story properly without doing that
I don't mind every night fun I like
broad comedy and if I had an idea
tomorrow for film is all slapstick
comedy and I get it interested me i
would not hesitate to do you know I
enjoy watching those Kourtney are second
exit necessarily I think you've really
mastered the art study of relationships
in your film these years and I was
wondering what you would say the
greatest less than you for me about love
said so I didn't I the only master the
art and study of relationships
throughout all your films of years and I
was wondering what you would say the
greatest lesson you learned about love
it well I pretend to someone else before
that about the important things in life
you never learn anything you know you
can learn technological things
learn about specific things but you
can't do problem you said that people
deal with in any subject substantial
subjects or romantic subjects you never
learn anything so you make a fool of
yourself from your 20 you're making fool
of yourself at 40 at 60 and the ancient
Greeks with dealing with these problems
they screwed up all the time people do
now all the world relationships between
men and women are very very tricky and
very difficult and you don't learn
anything it's not an exact science so
you can't learn anything you're always
going by instinct and your instinct
betray suppose you want what you want
when you want it and you know so it's
tough and most relationships don't work
out and don't last long when they do
work that and when you see one that's
really lovely it's a rarity it's great
that two people with all their complex
exquisite needs have found each other
and they all all the wires going to the
right places and you know it's great so
are there nothing to say
and I'm kind of kind of dad Devon faraci
we sound in the cylinder character
greats retirement that is that how you
feel as well or do you see a future
where you step away from the camera and
you don't retirement is a very
subjective thing our segment before that
their guy said only retire and if
they're happy they you know they travel
all over the world and efficiently their
grandchildren are there I don't know
what kind of man I think they get this
work at all and then there are other
people I'm one of that time that that
much to work all the time I just like it
I can't see myself retiring and you know
tada mizzou my saga retirement now maybe
somebody get a stroke my health holds
out you know
I don't expect to retire there's a money
could be that sooner or later guys the
back with Rome's get wise they say you
know this is not really worth suffering
I stopped giving you the money and then
but I still win the power I guys think I
feel keeley white suit paddle this
question is for Aundre and Ellen and
Brett heaven never worked with Woody
Allen before and having me have had some
expectations or some things that you
were excited about or hoped would happen
were here what was the experience of
thumb of working on this median working
with miserable life
I think I realized everything after the
next year I thought really I really good
I really realized average and I'm series
every I don't believe in it it's so
amazing for me it's so unbelievable so
weird in the same time it's a big yes
you came to me and really challenging
and anything that beginning was just I
was just shocked when excited so the
first day undergone for all day and then
say anything yes yes because it was so
scary trend I think you are amazing if
you know that know exactly I remember so
we spent on the first day to see each
other we didn't see each other you can
talk with each other the same thing when
I try and avoid the cash cuz they come
up with these questions
no one give man sir so so I avoid
speaking to the actors as much as
possible the mirror is flash magazine to
our body with all the films that
directed produced written and started
and all the awards of receive all
denominations is there one film that's
always going to do till they never
forget is it one bill that's just the
most memorable freedoms you know when
you make family such a shell which on
Derby know when you after then you're
working all day in the kitchen and
dicing and cutting and resources on you
don't want to eat that's why I always
feel about the films I work on it for a
year I've written it up under the actors
that news again I just never want to see
you again and when I begin a film I
always think that I'm going to make the
Bicycle Thief or revolution and this is
going to be the greatest they had ever
hit secular and then when I see what
I've done much bored and just am praying
that some embarrassment to me and so I
never you never been satisfied or even
pleased with film I make them fish I've
never looked at one after my first film
in 1968 never seen it since I just
cringe when I see them you can like them
because
chris is a big gap between what you
consider your body when you're writing
and you don't have to meet the test of
reality you're home you're right and
it's funny and it's beautiful romantic
and dramatic and and then you have to
show up on cold morning and the actors
are there you're there you don't have
enough of this and this goes wrong they
make a wrong choice on something and you
screwed up here and you see what you get
the next day you can't go back and the
essential difference between the
idealized filming your mind that what
you end up with that you're never you're
never happy you're never satisfied so
for me I never liked any of them I'm
always thankful that your ears bails me
out and some of them they fight in spite
of my just any Hall let me tell you with
any more started out that film was not
supposed to be what I wound up with I
the frame was supposed to be what
happens in a guy's mind and he was
supposed to see a stream of
consciousness in his mind and I did the
film and was completely incoherent and
nobody understood anything that went on
and the relationship between myself and
I named Eagles all anyone cared of kenna
bat and I that was not what I cared
about
one small part of another another big
campus that I had and the end I had to
reduce the film to just me Diane Keaton
in that relationship so I was quite
disappointed in the end of that movie as
I was with other foods one that were
very popular kind of assistance was a
big disappointment is I had to
compromise my original intention
tremendously survived the film so you
know you're asking the wrong person I I
easy disappear all we made the film and
we're here in health when you're
promoting it and everyone's saying what
a thrill this was and how great was the
word because person and out what you
know you think we made citizen the role
sounds this way at a promotional thing
you've seen the film and enjoy your
conclusion from it but it's always to me
less than less than prevents the piece I
had certain about his destiny tonight hi
mr. Allen revered a great pleasure first
of all I so much of it movies that I
love which this one does so well they
explore to me anyway fantasy and things
that you in your wildest dreams would
ever expect to have a Jew I no use of a
thing that wasn't necessarily something
thought about when writing was fantasy
and these big dreams part of that and
what are your thoughts when you look
back do you do you see that fantasy
element the fantasy of fantasy of the
stories you know all the characters and
situations that you know kind of a
larger than life is at each of them the
good question of what if what has
happened if I met this architect who I
admire so much should I invite it in
africa v if you're able to do this in
film in real life is generally much
della and never agree sad most of the
time but in film you know you control
everything that's going on so you can
indulge the most fantastic romantic
escapist kind of feelings and fantasies
you can do anything you want so it's
that's why it's very seductive than
pleasurable to earn your living making
movies you're not living in the real
world you wake up in the morning and
your your rug you go to work you
surrounded by women like this and
simulating guys or handsome and witty
and gifted and you make up stories and
everybody's got costumes or the music's
beautiful you live your life you know
not in the real world and you create
something that's completely fabricated
and status and you know it's it's great
but it's not real but it's funny you
know it is fun to do but it's the only
place you can do it is in
in section hi Jane Fernandes if you wire
Ellen I wanted to ask you I feel like I
saw you do something in this character
that we never really do before was there
can you talk a little bit about whether
there was anything new that you found to
exploring here as a former or a person
working would even though I remember
when Marion Cotillard was
and but I was I was grateful and also
taken aback by two and i don't know i
just was grateful for the opportunity to
do something
in my ass
the last question i promise i see with
iowa sup this round was 180 pound
fresher career for a long time we're
saying I lived for decades even in
duralyn whenever the New York's make a
film and the son of the last 10 years
we've had this whole vibrant array of
places on to it and I was wondering what
do you think that you gain from doing
that and it also seems that your thumbs
have had a more upbeat and you know fun
tone to them in a lot of ways lessee if
she felt that your official left or was
that unrelated this puts it up to the to
the moons of your phone yeah it was
strictly financial I going to make the
first one started his match point which
was not really up
but they gave me the money to make it in
London and so I you know I was happy to
make it there and then I found that
other countries started calling me
Barcelona wanted me like a gentleman and
then Paris and Rome and I get calls from
countries that asked me to come and make
films there so it's an interesting
experience and the change of venue
cannot do anything but help me right now
maybe I don't know 30 pictures in your
forties videos and then suddenly find
yourself you're working in London or a
smaller rum and their necessity of
accommodating to the Society of
surroundings forces you into areas that
you will not have otherwise explore and
so you make films and because of certain
freshness and consumerism and I've been
lucky
I've been coming out good and I'm sure
the fact that i'm not making their
maneja has been one contributing factor
I think match point would have worked in
New York originally written but doing in
London I know what what skated the
certain freshness I wasn't again in
shooting in Central Park or on Broadway
or Park Avenue and that alone and made
contribution just as wrong in this
picture the ceiling and the very Roman
sensibility and makes a contribution to
the picture that's beyond anything I can
contribute to it it's just the
pleasurable to the viewer to watch the
story unfold in that atmosphere so you
know as long as that works for me and
then keep putting the money up